my name is John Fultz and I'm here to
talk about some of the new things in the
version 11 user interface probably the
first thing to note about the user
interface is that we have at long last
moved on from courier to a new selection
for coding fonts courier was a very
serviceable and venerable font for its
day but display technologies have
improved and most coding editors have
tended toward more modern looking
sans-serif fonts
many Macintosh coding editors use menlo
but on Macintosh we decided to use a
font called source code Pro instead it
has many similarities to menlo but
visually it works better for our use of
boldface inputs and planes the outputs
on Windows we use councilís another very
popular choice for use by code editors
another place where we made a
significant changes in the styling of
messages at first glance you'll notice
that we made the messages a little less
techy in their presentation the message
code which looks like an excerpt from a
1980s assembly language program is now
hiding behind a mouse over also there's
a pop-up menu that includes among other
things a much more powerful tool for
finding the source of your message the
stack trace a stack trace is basically a
road map beginning at the top level of
the code you executed and from there
winding down the rabbit-hole of your
code as it was run by the system in this
case the stack trace wouldn't be very
interesting but on the next slide it's a
bit more useful because it's difficult
to reason about exactly where the one
over zero pops out by merely eyeballing
the code if we look at the stack trace
we can see the relationship of the
functions to one another as they're
being executed and pretty quickly figure
out where the one over zero is pop
another significant update to the system
is real-time spell checking now let me
preface this by saying don't worry you
won't normally see misspellings marked
in a slideshow as you're presenting I've
just turned them on here for
illustrative purposes real time spell
checking is something you see in a lot
of software you might wonder why it
hadn't made it into our system before
one of the interesting things about
real-time spell checking is that it
compels you to bring your a-game to the
spell checking business because if you
have systemic omissions from your
dictionary
those red wavy lines are going to show
up everywhere in people's documents for
example the better systems out there
today have evolved enough to understand
the spell checkers need to have things
other than the standard language you're
working in they need common names of
people cities businesses and other
entities but our software has even
greater needs since we're used in so
many different technical domains we need
to understand a lot of highly
specialized jargon and you can see some
examples of both of those things here in
excerpts which they stole from Wikipedia
with some misspellings which I can
easily fix by mousing over the word and
choosing the best option what we have in
version 11 is still a bit of a work in
progress but we have a lot of good data
to draw on when you look at what we've
done with Wolfram Alpha I think what we
have in version 11 is a pretty
impressive effort and there's a lot more
coming on this in the future and not
just in English either we're supporting
over 25 languages in version 11 and we
are putting continuing curation effort
into improving the existing dictionaries
and adding new ones as we go forward
this is something we're very committed
to it matters to us that our internal
and personal documents are clean of the
red wavy lines of spelling death and we
would like to hear input from our users
as well I also wanted to mention a
couple features that aren't brand new in
version 11
but we're introduced and releases after
version 10 we were just speaking of
internationalization and something else
we've done on that
to the feature we call code captions
here's the idea
like many programming languages the
Wolfram language is fundamentally skewed
to be more usable by those who read and
write English well we think hard about
the names we give things and we like to
think that we do a very good job of name
selection but that doesn't help you if
your English skills are poor or
non-existent some professional folks may
get by on memorization perhaps but
that's not so helpful when you're
wanting to change your national
education system height and code
literacy and a population of non-english
speaking students so we came up with the
idea of introducing captions a bit like
subtitles in a movie here I'm showing
the French code captions some of the
captions get clipped but they pop out
when you move your mouse over them if
you have code captions turned on they'll
show up everywhere code shows up even in
the help system by default the system
will detect your default language but
it's easy to override in the preferences
dialog another feature which isn't new
to version 11
but postdates version 10 is book import
note books have long had the neat
property that they are simply
expressions in the Wolfram language and
so documents are easy to manipulate but
it still requires a high degree of
knowledge about the specifics of the
note book format note book import lowers
that bar let's take a look for example
at the task of harvesting all the
hyperlinks from a notebook this was
possible before but it would have
required figuring out appropriate
patterns and probably messing with the
level spec argument to cases now I can
simply call notebook import and tell it
to look for the hyperlinks I can do all
sorts of these manipulations with
notebook import that would have been
possible but modestly challenging before
here's another one that's now easy maybe
I want a list of section and subsection
headings so I can automatically create
an outline no problem in fact here's the
outline for the notebook I'm currently
presenting from and as you can see I've
hit the last
my headings so I guess that means I'm
finished thank you for your time